I'm gonna take an elevator trip up to
the top of this very very tall building
and in the time it takes for the
elevator to go up to the top and back
down I'm gonna get a physicist to
explain the beginning of the universe to
me. Sounds easy right?
Okay so I learned a
bit about the Big Bang in high school
and what I kind of know is that the
universe started from a single point and
then there was a big explosion and
everything moved away from each other
and there was a lot of heat and pressure
and then that formed planets and the
universe is expanding but I want to know
what I've gotten wrong. Ah that's really
good so far. I guess one thing I'll
correct you on is just that it wasn't
really an explosion in the sense of... you
know there's a big darkness and the
universe is like going out into it. That
darkness doesn't exist the universe is
everything. So it's more of an expansion
than an explosion. And it was really hot
and dense as you said and then as the
universe cooled indeed we did form
protons and neutrons, hydrogen, and then
they would fuse together to form helium
and then we have the rest of the planets
forming later. But what was before? How did we get
the stuff to expand? We don't know is the
short answer
using our theories, general relativity and
particle physics, we can wind the clock
back to the very beginning about ten to
the minus 35 seconds after the Big Bang
and we can understand pretty much the
entire journey right down to that point
and then beyond that we really don't
know. That's where we hit the singularity.
What's a singularity? Well that's a point
of infinite pressure and density and at
that point - we're at the top. We're
halfway through. You have one right down
to explain the entire beginning of the
universe to me.
Do you think you can do it? I'll try. All right singularity...
At the singularity we've got a point where we
just don't know the physics anymore.
We've got black holes and the start of
the universe are points where we just don't
have the physics yet to understand
what's going on.
It's obviously got to be like a huge human
question like "what came before?" Do we
even have a way of starting to know? Yeah
we can make little extensions to our
theories that might give us hints. So like extensions to things
we already know are true? Right. Right. And so then you can sort of design
problems where you think okay well maybe
the universe is a membrane or it's formed
by like membranes colliding or you might
think about big crunches. What's the big
crunch? Well some people think that we
might be heading towards a point where
the universe gets back to being a
singularity and then it could go again.
Maybe we may not be the first of those
cycles. It could happen again and again
and again. But until we really understand
our own universe we won't be able to test
those ideas. So we're just guessing? Well
we're making educated guesses. Well I
guess that's the best we can do right
now. For now. Bye.Bye.
Wait no but what do
we make those theories on? Cause you can't
just speculate. You can't just go out
there speculating. That's more or less what it is. But like so... As a scientist you're not
allowed. You have to have it based on
something right? Yes so it's a
speculation based on things which small
extensions to our laws might allow yeah
so we don't have like a theory of
everything so we say, "oh well maybe with
this small addition", "if we just add this
one extra ingredient then maybe we can
have this process going on". An expansion process, a recollapse process,  multiple
universes, multiverses, multiverses...
What was really interesting to me in that
conversation was kind of challenging all
of these things that I'd heard a lot of
things about before, like the Big Bang,
and what came before the Big Bang and
really making it tangible because I
didn't realize but I definitely had the
assumption that the darkness was
something. That the universe was
exploding into but it's not. There was
nothing there before and I know that
sounds silly but it's just assumed
knowledge and then to hear how
scientists are kind of working with what
we already know to figure out what we
don't is actually really exciting
because
I didn't know that that's how they did
did it. I didn't know that they are using
theories that they can already prove and
then making a little change to it and
seeing if that works. And hearing that
makes me feel like we might actually not
be that far off knowing what came before
the Big Bang what came before the
singularity. What came before...
we might know.
Hey so if you enjoyed
watching me have my mind blown about the
beginning of the universe then stay
tuned because we are gonna have more
videos for you we had a lot of fun
filming this elevator pitch we actually
had to do it a couple times because a
guy in a suit kept getting into the lift
and it just kept distracting us,
especially Julian. That the universe was
static and infinite and just kept going
and ummmm ahh
If you have a
topic that you'd like to see us tackle
then you can leave it in the comments
below.
Please do because I cannot keep coming
up with these ideas myself. You can also
hit the subscribe button and get updates
as to what we are up to but until then
I'll see you next time.